and I'm with Jimmy Burke the national
treasure and we're right outside so the
bombing happened on at 133 West 23rd i
was at 208 that's worth Gotham comical
800 feet away 800 feet away if you if
you actually mapquested my wife senator
thing it's it's 800 feet away and boom
just this crazy sickening loud noise and
I turn right Jim and I go that was a
bomb do people start running right well
well we're so I'm right behind the first
door which is made of plastic so we
really felt it so boom this this huge
noise and I go we go running outside I
go that's a bomb lure eyes that smoke
you could smell it and there was just
you know that that quiet before this you
know the combo yeah oh well whatthebuck
there's that confusion and then I see
people running toward me who yeah what
did you do I said the Jimmy I go because
I might your instinct is to go toward it
to see what's going on make sure
everybody's okay but it's so sickening
because you know people got hurt and my
I thought people died because was so
loud right so you get so scared so uh
before that day told me I had four
minutes before I to get on stage I run
and I go Jim let's get back inside
because there could be another bomb
let's go back in so we go back inside
the guy goes you're on I go there was
just a bomb dude they got on either day
view what they were i go there was I'm
telling you there was a bomb how did you
not hear that but if you Gotham comedy
club you go way way in so late show so
you can't hear it crowds racing down
crowds already been listening 20 minutes
of stand-up now I come on hey everybody
it's me in my mind people have just been
killed in my mind there was a bomb in my
mind I'm could be more on in my mind
worse my cousins were coming to see me
too so I didn't know if they were you
know and Jimmy Burke had just literally
biked past that he had come up from the
east side on twenty-third street so he
lives i'm 27 where they found a bomb I
have blocked away from him so it was all
very close to home so I i was just kind
of all my pens but you know you're a pro
did you get up there doing you got up
and I did my thing okay i will admit i
was my sorry if you guys were there but
might you know i might have been a
little rushed i was a little nervous you
know sure
your minds a little bit yeah I was
depressed you get very depressed very
quickly it wasn't so much fear you get
your afraid but you saw it so doc rasik
God that the world is this way that
people get killed over [ __ ] so I i am so
I was worried on a lot of counts I get
up I do my standup crowd was great I did
about I got in 45 minutes in and the
off-duty cop walked up on stage and took
the mic out of my hand and said ladies
and gentlemen I'm so sorry cuz you know
what I did when he walked up I knew that
it was actually I went oh no because
they came into the club with machine
guns and the the cuz they had to
evacuate all the buildings and the guy
was not due to cloud guys I'm on the job
let me let me go get him off the stage
don't come up you know with guns so he
comes up just took it out of my hand
there's ladies and Jenna with a Q 8
really sorry and the first thing I said
I went oh no as I saw him walk up yeah
it is that that awful feeling was the
past the crowd calm or were they like no
everybody's common those situations it's
funny because nobody knows they didn't
hear they didn't they had no idea really
but what they do is they make you they
make you make a left that you make a
left out the thing everybody walks down
but you're always uneasy because where's
the next pump and they found a bunch of
new ones five yeah so see you and so
anyway I we went down on the Meatpacking
District straw my cousin's down there I
hope you guys hung out afterwards yeah
and I was with my two buddies who are
special agents because they do a
protection work for you United Nations
delegates Nations is the Intel yeah and
they they were getting all this Intel
from the FBI and they were able to tell
me some stuff that Jesus Christ so
smarten when I woke up and I turned onto
the end I like to get just every detail
I can out of that and and I read all the
news clippings all that they showed the
first photo like wheeling him into the
ambulance yeah I thought with a wounded
shoulder and he's like oh yeah [ __ ] I
was just like god i would pay anything
just to have a fake like like like like
I am your man see um dia and like I'll
take it from here fellows thank you ya
know yeah you shot them in are you sure
he right yeah okay just get all going
close this all right let's do
it and then just look at Mike some anti
for a dick punch that's like how you
doing where they shoot you how god man
thank god you're all right and then just
do something your momma Joyce no just
youtube check it out me pissing on this
terrorist here yep yep just you know it
helps with a bullet wounds to the
shoulder it stinks real bad I'm going to
do here is once you look me in the eye
I'm gonna take my thumb gonna dig it is
far into your wound as I possibly can
right that'll sting a little bit and and
my friend Brendan's gonna give you a
couple dick punches now listen he's
professional fighter so he's gonna
really lay in otay your dick in a knot
sir like literally try and tie it like
my shoe your pancakes are with your
genitals will be pancaked dude you got
Canelo young was he 24 yes young 26 27
27 yeah cannella get triple G's not that
young but he's very prime 32 so let's go
now is triple G only 32 I thought he was
36 guys actually 34 and 35 in the middle
yeah but you didn't fight forever so you
can't wait too long now so this is the
fight but you think they would learn man
I in who I triple G Kell Brook that was
a great fight is a big fight the thing
is is uh Canelo has way more to lose
than triple G triple G is not a drawl at
all yeah at least bit he's just not a
draw if he does a pay-per-view against
Kell Brook's in the States yeah I mean
I'd love to see the HBO numbers that
watch it that's not good what about
Canela GG canals covel Isles the huge
dollars that it be how to draw not drunk
crazy not a growing among five fans that
thought yeah in die hard fight fans
that's a great fight that's in November
I think wrote we might do a companion
for that I can't take it I'm so excited
about that fight that's gonna be crazy
triple G uh Canelo's the fight man
that's a fight that's the fight but
again Canelo has so much more to lose in
triple G are their styles would you say
similar uh no not really i did like
triple G and he can do it all man he can
do it all and he goes forward you know
Canelo does great when got one guy's
pressure and go forward that's why I'm
majoring in fight he's got such a good
fight man Briana quinta it doesn't
matter what do we talk about for this
show goes on sure does i think
anyone to you are a you are a cog in a
giant wheel it's good for a hit it's
good for him for sticking up for himself
and what's sad is all these guys we
mentioned are one hundred percent
correct it's off they're all too awful
they're all in the right place and they
all have a legit argument it does not
matter yeah you're dealing with a
corporation whose whole deal is bottom
line it's like dealing with a sociopath
it doesn't matter you are a number and
you have to play according to numbers
that's right in here is the protocol
that this corporation wants from you you
soldier and you will behave accordingly
now the thing is is if you look at this
so you have you have GSP saying this you
have I quinta saying this you have other
guy saying this get together you guys
all have huge influence especially GSP
especially I quinta look at the gym he's
out of think about it what jim has he
had about if that Jim decided no one's
gonna fight ty cuenta gets paid Chris
Weidman's from his gym is that Sarah
longer a man you're okay stacked gym
staff super crazy time a good guy so I
tell you what you don't say we don't do
you don't go silent and you don't go
that's the game chalked up to the game
cuz for every guy listen the show we
have a lot of Fighters listen I promise
you at some point your career it's gonna
happen to you you're gonna be I quick to
now hi Quinta's been out he's been
injured but he's a [ __ ] monster and
that kid has so much potential it's not
even funny he could be world champion
but he right now he's not he's coming
off a long way off so people forget
about but it's it's just a dog-eat-dog
world because like I've been paid me and
I'm good are you though this is gonna
happen you are you good company's worth
four billion are you really good though
and the other thing about being a smart
businessman or being a smart
entrepreneur is you learn from your
steaks and he acknowledged your mistakes
I've made a shitload of mistakes yeah on
the show marketing wise comments I've
made I've been kicked off shows because
that what I believe in I made a shitload
of mistakes I'll acknowledging my man up
to him at what point does dana white in
the UC go this reebok deals mistake man
we really [ __ ] up taking go well we're
making money we
don't care you guys have enough money
you have more money than God the
fighters man you made a mistake let's
just chalk it up to it let's figure out
another way to pay these guys maybe we
bring in another sponsor that can be on
the short so they get more money maybe
they can't wear reebok but now you got
harley-davidson on the shorts you have
dodged on the sugar those those those
sponsors in the Octagon who are they
paying dr. fight their pain you're
paying UFC yeah so why don't we put
those logos on every fighter give them a
few hit grand here now you think why not
it's too why would again the what but
again there's not one fighter I promise
you on this earth is going this reebok
is being great man there's even those
guys that sign a single deal just one
part of being a businessman and being a
successful biz man you can listen to
anyone you want they're all going to
tell you it's owned up to your mistakes
I promise you in not in his heart of
hearts Dana White knows this was a
mistake the Reebok deal is a huge
mistake you got your biggest Canadian
influencer signing with Bellator because
the Reebok deal that's a huge loss man
yeah and of course they go that's
nothing just a guy right now he's just a
guy if he's a he's a world champion over
there and the rest of the Canadian see
that and then they you start losing
power that's right it's a snowball
effect that's right but being us i gotta
tell you but being a smart person being
a smart entertainer being a smart
businessman you learn from mistakes but
you also own it yeah again i made a ton
of [ __ ] mistakes man a ton i'll own
every single one of them you guys ask me
I'll tell you exactly this I feel like
Bellator is going he Scott Coker is like
he kind of but it but you're not gonna
see a influence right away it's compared
to take some time but there be there
it's in their favor there they've got
some very exciting fights over there but
how how how how long would it go with
everyone including the fans if dana held
press conf was like man dude i've done
i've been the face of MMA especially the
UFC for how many years what I've done
for the sport is amazing and do in this
sport isn't where it's at without me
today he's all that's correct and we've
just sold for four billion dollars look
at his reebok deal I made a mistake I
respect what Reeboks done they make some
tremendous care but the pay structures
not is not what we want and guy
we're losing guys because of it we see
how upset everyone are not to mention
the outfits look ridiculous we're also
working on that too Brendan shop helped
us out some so here's the thing all in
all mysterious ailment has a design [ __ ]
I'm just [ __ ] representing the award
for best female actress coffee cod done
without him all right Dan so we'll do a
one more current event this one's just I
couldn't not do this it's just like the
headline was just entirely too funny
suspended teacher allegedly told student
to quote lick me lick me where I fart
it's not bad and then oh well for you
know get a picture of her oh this female
female this is the teacher the source
concert oh [ __ ] hey go she looks like
louis ck with red hair Nick me where I
see it she teaches 10 to 12th grade I a
dunvale secondary schools involuntary oh
yeah she copied somebody book tears
here's just about laundry list of quotes
of her her telling a student who brought
coffee to class get that [ __ ] thing
out of here telling another student that
huge is bloody pedophile telling another
student I've never said this to a
student before but [ __ ] you that's great
cause it's debate not masturbate ting oh
my good after a student offered to buy
her muffins in exchange for a passing
grade you mean a bribe I'd be able to
[ __ ] for a week because of all that
fiber she's great Oh what's her name she
told her once one females do you know
the jokes like a frumpy old lady God
Doug she's great to leave it or not not
her first time getting in trouble it's
cool [ __ ] you fine no she's just
suspended for a month without back bring
her back what's her name was it he's be
gone for a month right material girl can
destroy these kill [ __ ] Jennifer green
Johnson free a Quentin Jennifer green
Johnson free I quite dead Jennifer green
shows that it's in Canada today virmani
wow this is Tom papa and the great Tom
papa who I go back I think 25 years with
a great stand-up comic I think I think
we were hanging out 20 I was just
texting my nephew before I came in and
he's 20 and I'm just saying hello so I
said what's up and I was saying what's
up is kind of like an old guy yeah hello
what would you say now to an 18 year old
if you just hitting your boy up SJP sup
yo sup its shortest language is always
changing I know and we're and they and
it kind of kicks you out like the old
lion yeah it was a text it's all about
getting shorter so was it t yl it took
me forever to figure that out talk to
you later yeah yeah it all depends
sometimes you say hi Hitler like the
kind of here you know depends on where
you are you're a bunch of your friends
yeah I didn't we joke around like that
yeah like if you're in Germany and then
the 40s well and you have blond hair
blue eyes hi Keith LA and now it's just
a little mustache emoji just a little
short is Jordan it down it's just a
little handling their habits knocking
boots I'm not saying I'm races I just
belong to an order right right strict
membership routers which is very
organized in general is weird and you
have to be kept like whenever we're in
these big business means i have to say
certain stuff like you know i used the
word dope i'll say right fresh or sick
or you know some of that old school me
on there like dope fresh sick right
that's just so dope I try and go real
retro so it seems like I'm being cool
but it's really just covering up like I
don't know any of the new stuff like
i'll say swell and groovy and me all the
time about that yeah she kind of
protects me frank says gee whiz you is
like exist gee whiz the [ __ ] are you
Robin I'm Batman am I do I look like I
was gee whiz Brendan like [ __ ] I just
did one yesterday where I screwed up a
message is a date to somebody and like
no you're wrong I'm like ah crab apples
ripe apples that's a good one too you
know they become dissociated with the
feeling
of human human interaction it's a same
thing in sports in the UFC I won't
mention any but there's certain people
the UFC brass where they see you know
these gladiators fight so much they
forget what's actually going on human
right yeah they just it is that's a
human being and he has a family try and
feed his friends and our family friends
and all that yeah so they they become so
kind of just it's it's normal for them
yeah so the way they treat the guys or
even NFL i remember when i was doing pro
day someone took a measurement of my the
length of my hand and there it was a
scout from i think the bangles is a
bengals and there's all these Scouts
there and they're doing all these
measurements and that you know they went
from school to school and that were
their fourth school in two days or some
[ __ ] like that and they're just so used
to it any uh they measure my handing us
not know there's no way he's catching on
football yes too small it's 97 next it's
like wow holy oh my god [ __ ] I've cut
prior G Gillian balls in my life what
the [ __ ] are you talking about my god
but it's good just like your like your
cattle tool you're 13 not way too big
weight to be given prospectin uh what
else we got it's like become on your
announced I was for this is my dream
yeah he saw a whole life it's literally
like who the [ __ ] are you but even with
auditions and and and I've been
auditions here where they're like next
yeah like all right I'm I get it man
this out you I gotta play the game you
gotta treat me like a [ __ ] human
being here to tell you I don't need this
gig I another gig that [ __ ] kicks ass
I'm just here because my agent sent me
here yeah treat me like a [ __ ] human
I'm gonna take my dick out and piss on
everybody yeah you know that's the thing
when you have another gig it gives you
power and that when i started making it
as a comedian i would show up i started
like not going to the commercial
auditions then when I would show up if
the line was too long I just walk out
hinata me I'm like to know but it was up
through that in here the tebow thing was
such a great example of it because
people were against him from day one
just ripping them apart online just
awful then he then he comes reboots and
does this baseball tryout
and it's I I actually played for my
daughter who's 11 who's just in
gymnastics and basketball and just
starting as an athlete and I showed his
press conference when he hadn't made the
team appetit you'd try it out and did
the whole thing and he just gave like
this little he was like this is my dream
I was I to dreams when i was a kid i
want to be a quarterback can have and
leave my friends and win the game and I
loved hitting a baseball and this is my
dream he's just he's built he's just
doing all the right stuff and he gave
this just this little couplet of this is
your dream you gotta shut everybody else
out here go after it and just the purity
of what he was saying and I played it
for my daughter and I could see it
resonate with her like this was a real
inspiring moment from this guy she knows
nothing about yeah but but what is what
Tim represent your home sent correct I
mean to cut you up tip but Tim's thing
was I know people are gonna say this is
just the mac I don't care I've and he
goes I've never made a decision based
off what other people are gonna say yeah
don't care I don't and he doesn't he he
did rape that way he doesn't look at
social media he doesn't look at the news
he does that he owes I'm doing this so
the u.s. critique all you want over here
yeah the monkeys in the trees or the
Sheep go ahead and critique the lion he
was a Heisman winner who played in the
NFL when ase cha Eun ofc West
championship yeah beat the Pittsburgh
Steelers you like oh and then now 22
teams offered him a professional
baseball contract yeah youyou riders
over here the cheeto fingers go ahead
keep critiquing he's just gonna keep
doing this the best that moment was just
like for me it's it like he rode the
storm and he's just he's still great
he's still better and more peace in his
own mind than anybody out so I was like
this is a great excuse ports yeah oh I'm
so glad this is her UFC to know I don't
but I'm gonna say I'm gonna say because
I watched it as a fan you watch all of
them with no but I mean I I really
wanted to see this one with I want to
see how he do and I'm not a see among I
would say that it had a huge it was a
huge boost give us an a big money like
so so over a million would be crazy okay
it would for a mine a millions like that
this is going in like the panty
on a view of calm top top town over a
million half a million no they don't go
ahead don't tell us yet yeah well it's
750 i must say i will say right under a
million i'll say around 800-900 you two
are about the same distance from the
right answer it's looking like he pretty
much doubled the early estimate for what
it was going to do so we're looking at
me somewhere between 650 and 800,000
probably probably topping closer to the
800,000 wow which would make it the
biggest UFC pay-per-view without Rousey
McGregor or Lesnar on it since UFC 180
to Gina wait Xena white knows how to
make money she's and take it easy cuz
you could put any major store on there
and do it you know I'm saying right yeah
I'm saying if you have Morgan Freeman on
there you know let's take it easy jo
genius Wow I'm gonna beat you well yeah
anyone the thing is I'm Morgan he's a
he's a he's a big deal we all wanted to
see kind of this this show from a
business aspect it off he paid off um
that's interesting man I'm does this
does this make it more likely that we're
gonna get a bunch of more these more
kind of Notre lined ridiculous fights in
the future no I don't think so because I
think you might see CM Punk in like two
or three years tried again here but
maybe I don't know I I think every
wrestler who had the idea of fighting
saw that was like holy [ __ ] I'm not
doing that that's embarrassing yeah it
would it wasn't good I applaud the guy
for taking a risk and put himself out
there i'm a hater on for that but it
just that's what happens man you gotta
put the time in you just can't just walk
in and do it no one walked away from
that was like I think he could [ __ ] I
think you do not one person the CM Punk
fan club the present fan clubs like god
damn it god damn it can we go back to so
much lamp I get hurt yeah he didn't get
hurt he's gonna make bank though cuz he
gets paper you percentage now and good
for him good friend yeah good for it is
worth it and then with the UFC you know
but you get but you can't run a business
off that you know that's like
he still can't get the new iphone till
februari you I think can only pull that
card maybe once every three or four
years otherwise you got it you got a
[ __ ] show on your hands like whoohoo
yeah it's a circus hughesnet let's say
the rock once you know big of a paper
you draw the rock would be say the rock
wants to do it and then it's
professional wrestling hmm like we're
not Morgan Freeman I will kick your ass
Morgan Freeman fighting Dustin Hoffman I
paid for that Dustin Hoffman Morgan
Freeman and robert de niro will be
reffing Morgan Freeman it is on